University of Wisconsin professor
Jennifer Ratner Rosen Hagen who is
Frederick Nietzsche Frederick Nietzsche
was a German 19th century German
philosopher who wrote many many many
many books a philosophy in all sorts of
different forms and all of them to some
aphoristic some essay istic some longer
form critiques and all of them had
something to do with the challenge of
universal truth so he he he took as his
enemy the notion of universal truth and
pretty much all of his work has
something to do with his effort to tear
it down excavate it look at the history
of that idea and to show that anything
that we take to be universal like Oh God
are human creations but they're not
rooted in nature or necessity they're
not mirrors of reality he wrote at one
time God is dead and he wrote that God
is dead and this make first makes its
appearance in his gay science and in it
the gay science in it it's a an aphorism
and it's called the madman and so the
aphorism is he's playing with this this
idea that a madman runs into the to the
town square and says god is dead god is
dead we have killed him you and I and
everybody says oh he's crazy oh he's
crazy and he realizes oh my time has not
come yet and so there he's announcing
what what's gonna be basically his
intellectual project for the rest of his
his writing life before he goes insane
and that is the notion that God is dead
what troubled Nietzsche was that in over
the course of 19th century as in
particular Germans became more modern
and more secular that they continued to
go to church and pray to a god that they
didn't really believe in anymore in
other words he thought that modern
thought modern science the forces of
modernity were undermining the basis of
religion and yet he said people still
held held onto it they still
clutched onto it because they were too
terrified to live without it and this he
found really despicable and that's
that's that's what he tries to work out
in his philosophy where did we teach how
did he come about was he well known at
this time
Nietzsche well we have to sort of
separate the myth from the the from the
reality which is that Nietzsche did have
moments of modest Fame actually his
first book the birth of tragedy had a
pretty big reception but then he did
fade into obscurity he was a philosopher
in Basel
so a professor of language history of
language the genealogy of language but
the academic life wasn't for him he he
suffered from a lot of physical ailments
ailments pardon me
so I mean historians and philosophers
debate why did he why did he have such a
tough time in the Academy although some
of us in the Academy and I would say
still under that much but anyway
Nietzsche taught for ten years in Basel
with some success but due to reasons
that we can only sort of imperfectly
suss out was it his health was it what
he said which is that he needed to break
free
Nietzsche breaks free lives on a pension
the rest of his life and gets to inhabit
the image of the free thinker that he so
exalts and worships in his own
philosophy so but Nietzsche didn't have
a huge readership for for most of his
productive life and I say productive
life because in 1889 he has a nervous
collapse and spends the last 11 years of
his life in a very declining state I
mean and ends up in a totally vegetative
state
and dies in 1900 he's discovered so how
does nature become Nietzsche he's
discovered precisely in those months
when his health is declining shortly
before this mental collapse
so one of the terrible ironies of
Friedrich Nietzsche's life and the
posthumous life of his ideas is that
it's in the moment when his when
intellectually and mentally you know
there's a closing of accounts for him
that's the moment when the floodgates
open and he becomes the superstar that
he is today who discovered him how was
he - he was discovered this is a little
tricky because there's always a quest
for a priority people were reading
Nietzsche but were those people being
read but I think it's fair to say that
the the Danish critic George Brandis who
himself had a big audience in the late
19th century he is credited with
discovering each and I think that's a
fair assessment that he brings the most
famed to Nietzsche and they actually do
have a brief correspondence in that last
year just as madness is closing in on
Nietzsche and Nietzsche thinks finally
finally someone recognizes my genius and
then lo and behold he has mental
collapse in Turin and that's pretty much
the end of his productive life
so Brandes is credited largely with kind
of getting the word out in northern
european circles that Nietzsche's
Nietzsche's one to watch and that's when
each his reputation boom really takes
off who followed him who liked his work
what kind of people what kind of
everybody everybody atheists
religionists the left the right women
men black whites old people young people
so Nietzsche that's not immediate
because he needs to be translated yeah
Nietzsche's not translated in earnest
until the late into the 1896 1897 is the
first round of translations then there's
another major effort of translations
that happen in the early 20th century of
course in the late 19th century in early
20th century a lot of educated Americans
could read German
so people were reading him you know in
the original but it really did require
the translations for him to take off
Henry who had eight why am i calling him
Henry
HL Mencken you've seen the code by Henry
eight
Menken has a lot to do with Nietzsche's
superstardom no it's not to say that
there weren't other folks who were
reading niche and popularizing Nietzsche
in the United States before Menken but
Menken is the one who writes the first
full-length monograph on Nietzsche in
1908 and that's where we get a kind of
full-on synopsis about Nietzsche's life
his travails his struggles with
Christianity his struggles with health
we get a little bit about each of
sexuality it wouldn't be Minkin if there
wasn't a little something racy thrown in
and then we get Nietzsche's ideas boom
and this book sold widely and sold well
and it helped do two things it helped
really establish in each his reputation
in America but it did something else
which is of course it helped men can
become Menken so if somebody says I love
friedrich nietzsche i agree with him
what are they saying to you professor if
they're just saying that not much
because someone I'm going to use the
example of chest-thumping
atheists and Bible something Christians
could both make that claim about
Nietzsche and that's what's so startling
about his reception is that he doesn't
track right or left
he doesn't track religious or secular he
tracks or rather he tracks all over our
intellectual spectrum so just the
statement I love Nietzsche doesn't tell
me much of anything other than that's an
utterly conventional experience a - you
know find Nietzsche so powerful in fact
I think what's so so interesting is how
many people will say and have said over
the course of the late 19th 20th century
of course until our own time how they
felt when they read Nietzsche he was
speaking to them personally so one of
the things I argue in the book is that
Nietzsche becomes a superstar public
philosopher by way of private longings
and private fears
you have a strange you have a disturbed
look on your face who wouldn't like
Friedrich Nietzsche them oh there are
plenty of people who don't like
Friedrich who don't like Friedrich
Nietzsche and there were things not to
like
he didn't say very nice things about
democracy
he didn't say very nice things about
women he didn't say very nice things
about equality and so if these are
things that matter to you you're gonna
take issue with him
so let me give you a concrete example of
what's what's to like and what's not to
like about Nietzsche and oh gosh I can
take any anyone but I'll take one of the
more spectacular examples and that is
the Leopold and Loeb trial of 1924 so
Leopold and Loeb are two University of
Chicago students who think that they are
the uber mentioned that they are what
Nietzsche had in mind when he wrote
about the uber mention and they wanted
to prove it to themselves just beyond
the ubermensch is the the Superman it
gets translated as the Superman in fact
the Superman as in Superman comic which
we tend to think of as you know
Americana has its roots and Nietzsche's
ubermensch
in fact the two men the two boys are men
who come up with Superman were readers
of Nietzsche so that's just a little and
there's many cases like that I mean even
I think the fact that we have the word
uber you know but uber I think comes
into our language in the way that it
does by way of the ubermensch anyway but
that we're talking about an example
where we have two views that say they
have the right Nietzsche and that is
Leopold and Loeb they read Nietzsche
they think that he's the they're the
Superman he had in mind and so they want
to prove it to themselves and so they
kill they kidnap and kill a
fourteen-year-old boy Bobby Franks and
the south side of Chicago they get
caught it turns out that they weren't so
uber as they thought Clarence Darrow the
famed trial attorney becomes their
defense lawyer and he's also a reader of
Nietzsche but he's not a murderer
in fact he's quite sure that that's not
what Nietzsche had in mind and so the
interesting thing about the whole
Leopold and Loeb trial which is trying
to save these boys from these young men
from being killed themselves is how
Darrow had to not make to both say the
reason why they did this is because
Nietzsche is toxic and the dangerous
thinker and they misunderstood him and
yet Nietzsche is an important thinker
that we need in modern life but we need
to handle him with care so so it's I'm
just something like that the Leopold and
Loeb trial you see those sorts of
negotiations where a Nietzsche is both
you know public enemy number one as we
see with with a murder but we also see
with a Clarence Darrow saying no
Nietzsche is the thinker that we
Americans need in order to embrace
modern life political movements that
have co-opted Nietzsche
oh so many I think the one that I mean
really the the whole 20th century is a
story of co-optation I think the one
that surprises my readers the most or at
least when I get letters from readers or
I get or come into contact with readers
its Nietzsche the hidden Nietzschean
origins of black power
so Huey P Newton was a reader of
Friedrich Nietzsche and in Nietzsche he
discovered he discovered a lot of things
in Nietzsche but what he understood from
Nietzsche is he needed an e to tell him
that the things that your culture tell
you are true and are universal it's in
fact made up or it's a it's a product of
history it's a product of chance it's
somewhat arbitrary but it's not true and
so don't take the voice of a racist
culture as the voice of your own inner
conscience
yeah and this is what Sochi for Huey P
Newton this is what Nietzsche did for
African America
is to help them hear that they no longer
had to pray to the white man's God they
no longer had to make themselves
prostrate to a religion and in his view
that made them supplicants and that they
shouldn't take this morality which tries
to discipline them and keep them down as
something universal as something
timeless and so Huey P Newton is is
really intellectually if you will
cutting his teeth on Nietzsche as he and
Bobby Seale are coming together and
formulating the basis of black power
World War two no the the reason why I
say is there are I don't know of any
other philosopher in history
that's blamed for two world wars but
Nietzsche was so you can't just quickly
world war two I actually think is the
more interesting story here because all
the ways in which in each his reputation
is just so terribly damaged but just
quickly if I'm a world war one Nietzsche
when World War one breaks out and this
is so shocking to American observers it
starts to come out you know its
Nietzsche its Nietzsche its nature
rumors of German ministers preaching
Nietzsche from their pulpits it wasn't
hard to listen and hear traces of
Nietzsche and philosophy behind the
blood and iron imperialism of World War
Germany during World War one and so
Nietzsche is yoked to World War one and
has a very hard time well those who want
to try to save his reputation and say
this wasn't what he intended this is
just the misuse of Nietzsche had a
really hard hard time afterwards then of
course Leopold and Loeb don't do much
for his reputation and then with the
rise of Hitler not not Mussolini
initially who was a reader of Nietzsche
and an enthusiast of Nietzsche Hitler
the rise of Hitler in particular was the
more
I think those sort of the more
terrifying development so over the
course of the 1930s as we see the
specter of Nazism and then later as
Americans started to see Mussolini as a
greater threat than they initially had
it was not hard to find nietzsche and
traces behind Nazi philosophy and
Mussolini's fascism and so lo and behold
Nietzsche you know yet again is seen as
the the author and visionary of what
would become world war two
of course Nietzsche wrote up things that
were not so hard to turn into to make
him implicated he wrote of the rise of
the blond Beast so which people thought
it took to be his celebration of the
Aryan race his sister actually was a
proto Nazi and in her her closing years
she welcomes Hitler to the Nietzsche
archive so there's a there's a linkage
to Hitler and some very unfortunate
pictures of Hitler and Elizabeth
Forrester Nietzsche with the Nietzsche
bust at the nature archive so in the
American imagination Lee Nietzsche
really gets linked to World War two and
the entire Nazi ideology that not here
we have the Germans who didn't just want
an uber mensch but they wanted an uber
race and we know the language of unter
mention the subhuman people which was
all throughout germany during during
world war ii nietzsche was just
implicated in all of this what's his
reputation today in hood
who's the anti Nietzsche philosopher
whose ins is there such a thing oh
there's plenty yeah but I don't think
there is interesting sure I mean George
Santayana is not a thinker that we talk
about much today though we should
because he was a towering intellectual a
towering philosopher and poet and
novelist in the early 20th century
he thought Nietzsche was
thing that was wrong with what he called
the German mind that hypertrophied self
yeah the hyper aggrandize self he
thought that that German the German what
he called the German mind or the German
temperament and he traces this back to
content up through Hegel and the
Nietzsche becomes the great exemplar is
an intellectual or a mind that just
didn't couldn't deal with limits
so he actually referred to Nietzsche's
amateurish and adolescent so he is
pretty dismissive of Nietzsche and
that's an example of a thinker who I
think is a very robust thinker and a
careful thinker
there are plenty there are plenty others
I actually think an interesting case
here is an example the example of Alan
bloom who in the reception of his famous
book the the closing of the American
mind you know a blockbuster book Alan
bloom says you know what's the wrong
with higher education it's killing the
souls of our children they're getting
all this pluralism they're getting all
this multiculturalism but what they're
not getting is great ideas and they're
not getting the the challenges of those
great ideas so it's how that how higher
education is impoverishing our nature
our the the the souls of our of our
children and nietzsche is right there
all along he even talks about the
Nietzschean ization of american
intellectual life and according to bloom
he thinks that so much of what is wrong
in late night late 20th century
intellectual life is that intellectuals
are reading their Nietzsche and kind of
like what George Santayana says they're
tired of universal truth they're tired
of power they're of someone else's power
they're tired of Authority and so he he
says that all that the counterculture of
the 1960s is nursed on Nietzschean I'm
anti authoritarianism and he said this
is it's one thing to have these kinds of
protests in the streets it's another
thing to bring them into the Academy and
make such a ruckus so he's very critical
of the uses of Nietzsche so I hit the
his button here if you read how
everyone's talking about Allen Bloom's
book and they were talking and they were
talking and they were talking because as
you know it was a major major major
blockbuster people picked up on it aha
you know nietzsche of Allan bloom blames
Nietzsche you know it's the Nietzschean
ization of our American intellectual
life blah blah blah blah blah so you
would think that Alan bloom you know had
a problem with Nietzsche he didn't he
thought Nietzsche was a genius he loved
Nietzsche he wrote beautifully about
Nietzsche he wrote longingly about
Nietzsche he thought Nietzsche was a
genius and his problem was that he
thought he was in a culture of
intellectual pygmies who could not
appreciate the genius of Nietzsche so
and so what he's actually doing in the
closing of the American mind which i
think is such an interesting move he's
not really blaming Nietzsche for the
impoverishment of American intellectual
life he had the sort of
anti-authoritarianism that he finds so
despicable he's blaming what he says is
readers who just aren't up to the task
of truly understanding this great genius
so again that's not someone who's
critical of Nietzsche per se although he
has a reputation for having you know
pinned all the failures of late 20th
century American intellectual life on
Nietzsche quite the opposite what he's
trying to do is keep his own private
Nietzsche a Nietzsche in his own image
against what he sees as the slavish
inadequate impoverished American
intellectual life that just can't handle
these powerful ideas Jennifer Ratner
Rosen Hagen you've written a biography
of Friedrich Nietzsche are you a fan if
I may I would say I that I would people
call it a biography of Friedrich
Nietzsche but it's actually a biography
of his ideas as they come to life in
America so one of the things I say in
the book is that it's not this is not
actually a book about Nietzsche in fact
some readers have been disappointed of
course he crops up quite a bit
but the book is not about Nietzsche I'm
an American historian I'm an American
intellectual and cultural historian my
interest is the history of American
thought and culture over 19th and 20th
century what I discovered is you can't
when you get to the late 19th century in
the 20th through the 20th century you
can't talk about American intellectual
life without talking about Nietzsche's
presence his curious presence really and
his influence so anyways it's just a
little modest correction here it's not
about Nietzsche it's about us so every
reading of Nietzsche I'm not listening
whether HL Mencken or Clarence Darrow or
Walter Kaufmann who become so important
to redeem neech after World War 2 or
Shoei P Newton or Alan bloom are getting
him right or wrong I don't think that's
the interesting question for a historian
to ask what I'm trying to do is listen
in to what they have to say about
Nietzsche to listen to see what that
tells us about American intellectual
life in that particular moment so the
book is actually not about Nietzsche
it's about us it's about our
intellectual life and it's about our
coming to coming to our own ideas about
truth about democracy about Christianity
about God by way of Nietzsche
but I'm dodging the question has he in
your view been a positive influence in
American political and cultural life uh
you know what that's incredible I've
never been asked that question I think
he's a necessary influence because I
think he's right I mean I think there's
a lot of Duncan what he says there's a
lot of grandstanding in my chisme but
you clear away some of that gunk and the
the the ideas I think are ideas that we
had to him had to come to terms with
which is again to just repeat what I had
said earlier the notion that so much of
week what we take to be universally true
whether it be God whether it be
democracy whether it would be whatever
it is
Nietzsche gave us a way of looking at
those ideas those truth claims to see
their origin
and their genealogy and Nietzsche helped
Americans to see that so many truth
claims are not rooted in reality
they're rooted and power they're rooted
in needs they're rooted in fear they're
rooted in longing but they're not
necessarily rooted in truth and I think
this is this is necessary I mean they
for any culture truthfully but
especially American culture because we
have from the start been a very
pluralistic culture of many languages of
many religions of many ethnicities of
different races and so part of what it
means to be American right from our
earliest years here is contested truth
is a pluralistic sensibility is a land
of many religions and many beliefs and
we haven't we never did a good job of
negotiating or we didn't do it that
great a job of negotiating this prior to
Nietzsche but Nietzsche becomes his
ideas become important as we negotiate
this moving forward so in answer to your
question do you I think is a positive
force yeah and he's also been a negative
force although he had nothing to do with
it because he was long dead but and his
ideas have been read in all sorts of
curious ways but I think as I as I said
I think he was a necessary force and in
that regard salutary force because he
helped Americans to confront fundamental
problems that we've had which is
problems of living in a pluralistic
society and doing so in a humane way and
and and and for that I think we'll here
I'll just because they story many people
were grateful in the 20th century that
they had Nietzsche to think with about
these issues University of Wisconsin
professor Jennifer Ratner Rosen Hagin
teaches history here at the University
here's her book American Nietzsche the
history of an icon and his ideas you're
watching book TV on c-span too